Let's go to the phone lines at six one seven
eight three zero forty seven fifty.
Starting today with our caller from the two
seven zero area code.
Caller from two seven zero.
What's your name?
Where are you calling from?
Western Kentucky, you said Damon from western
Kentucky.
Go ahead.
Yes, sir.
Well, I was just calling.
First of all, I want to point out I'm sorry.
I'm kind of nervous here.
That's OK.
But Biden and Harris are not my first choice
at all.
OK, thank you.
I think the worse worse you could've gotten,
that would have been Biden Clow, which are
OK.
After a little bit of agonizing.
I decided I am voting Biden just because even
though I'm in Kentucky and I think if I voted
third party, it wouldn't matter much anyways.
I want to see Trump lose big in the popular
vote just so he can't say, oh, this was rigged.
I think there really needs to be a great big
coalition rejecting him.
I agree.
I mentioned this last week in that we have
to run up the score.
Obviously, this is an Electoral College contest.
But given that, we anticipate Donald Trump
might either try to challenge the results
or claim it was rigged or whatever, a bigger
margin in the popular vote is better than
a smaller margin.
So I agree with you.
Exactly.
I didn't want to say as you more Morgus pragmatic,
left leaning people.
I do think one way we can screw up is we don't
need the same people.
Yes.
Feel different.
We need to explain to them this is the best
description I ever heard.
And forgive for going on too long.
Make this quick.
There is a left wing YouTube who said if you
believe in what Bernie and what AOC stand
for and you look at the amount of work they
put in and what they fought for.
If you think, oh, we're just going to punt
this and let Trump get it because right.
Get the right president, you pretty much helping
destroy everything they work for.
Because I don't think Biden is necessarily
going to become progressive when he gets elected,
but it's going to be a lot easier to convince
him and Harris
to go for Medicare for all and go for free
college and legalizing marijuana.
It is Trump.
And I think we have to understand that and
we have to look at the down ballot votes and
we have to look at this as a way of, for lack
of a better term, helping to infiltrate the
Democratic Party.
Well, that sounds really Machiavellian.
Well, but it makes sense.
And I think, you know, Matt, you and I don't
think we're going to get Medicare for all
because not because of Biden, but because
most Democratic senators don't even support
it.
But that's a that's a specific thing.
You're completely right that with Trump, we
get zero percent of what Bernie wanted.
And with Biden, we probably definitely get
10 percent and are in a position to get another
50 percent.
I mean, listen, it's just numbers, right?
And so the only real argument would be I want
to destroy the entire system, to build it
back up in the image that I value.
But there's no historical example that tells
us that's how change happens.
So I would reject it on historical grounds.
But you and I, I think, are on the same page,
of course.
And one more thing and then I'll let Bob stop.
I started with Cornel West, and I think the
best thing he said is he said basically implied
he's going to vote for Biden and Harris.
But he said that does not mean I endorse them.
That does not mean that I'm not going to criticize
them.
And I think we need to be able to point out
when they do something wrong.
Just like I remember when your your big Bernie
supporter.
But when Bernie did something you thought
was the wrong thing, you would not pay by
it, right?
Yeah.
I mean, listen.
All that voting for one person over another
means is you think you're better than that
other.
Do you think they are better than that other
person?
That's all that I mean, it doesn't mean anything
else.
And then we go and we do do the work.
All right, my friend, thank you for the call.
I appreciate it.